becoming a guide dog for the blind is
really hard only a few puppies make the
grade a new study suggests pups with
overbearing mothers aren't less suited
for the complexities of the job this
means the most successful dogs raised
with tough love Elaine Quijano of our
streaming network cbsn is at the
seeing-eye guide dog training center in
Morristown New Jersey Elaine good
morning good morning now a trainers look
for specific traits when they are
deciding whether or not a dog can make
the cut at programs like this one but
researchers say those puppies whose
mothers are somewhat less attentive are
actually better suited than puppies
whose moms doted on their every move at
just over seven weeks old these golden
retrievers and these chocolate black and
yellow labs are already in training as
future Guide Dogs for the Blind here
they learn to interact with others adapt
in new surroundings and remain calm
while under stress skills that
researchers have linked to how these
puppies were raised the new study finds
more intense mothering was associated
with program failure and mothers whose
nursing style required greater effort
were more likely to produce successful
offspring dr. Dolores Holley is director
of k9 medicine and surgery at the
seeing-eye one of the findings was that
pups who were perhaps overly mothered
their moms were overly attentive to them
spending a lot of time with them licking
them copiously that those pups were not
as likely to be selected as guides
researchers followed ninety-eight
puppies from birth to adulthood watching
more than 115 hours of puppy cam video
to track different types of maternal
behavior for example here the more
attentive mom is lying down alongside
her sleeping pups while in this one the
mom taking a more tough love approach
gives her puppies space to move around
the ability to overcome obstacles
whether it be to find food or navigate a
street curb is a key factor in the
success of a seeing-eye dog with boy
instructors Joan Markey says dogs who
exhibit a fear of the unknown don't make
the cut if they were afraid of the world
they're not gonna be a good guide if
they get worried by loud traffic people
making loud noises anything that makes
them afraid to the point where they want
to bolt and run that would get them out
of the program but while these
personality traits may not be desirable
for guide dogs leading the blind experts
say they could be well-suited to other
canine callings
Clive Wynn is a dog behavior scientist
guide dogs have to be very very calm as
adults
whereas military working dogs have to be
very alert very on the ball very
energetic and so different patterns of
rearing produce quite different outcomes
in dogs around 70% of dogs who enter a
guide dog training programs like this
one are successful that number could go
up should less attentive parenting
styles be encouraged by trainers and
adopted by dogs themselves Margaret I'm
so jealous lean yes